like this so i could see him butter
oh snap
daddy
[Laughter]
oh man cardi b may not hear the end of
this one from offset after allowing
their daughter culture to get press-on
nails i was like oh snappity-snap snap
i'm nervous cardi took to instagram to
show off her three-year-old daughter's
fresh manicure and it's a sight to see
she's so precious seriously and culture
looks too cute with her pink nails all
done up say thank you jenny for my nails
[Music]
let me see
but cardi thinks culture's dead might
not exactly feel the same way once he
sees the mature manicure but one thing
we do know is offset is all about
pampering his little girl we saw him
flexing his nail tech skills last year
you'll really be having her do whatever
the hell she wants my baby
yep seems like offset is the kind of dad
that will do anything to put a smile on
culture's face stay pretty
we'll have to wait and see if offset
approves of this latest set but when it
comes to culture well she's never shy
about her opinions
shut up you [ __ ]
why you say that because she's getting
my nerves
ah
back in may culture called out her mom
for cursing during their mother-daughter
baking sesh you gotta
you gotta you gotta
i will come yeah it's bonding moments
like that that cardi says make
motherhood a dream it's like a feeling
that it's indescribable
it's like
like
love joy it's a
switch
you know what i'm saying it's like an
automatic smile this is like she loves
me and culture seems to love the camera
just like her mom which we saw last week
when little k crashed her mom's
instagram live
yeah
it tastes like medicine you shouldn't
but like grown people medicine like
your medicine tastes like
candy mine tastes like
death like you should not even like
don't even get toasted at all
yeah it was a tipsy dance session filled
with alcohol infused whipped cream from
cardi's own line and straight up tequila
we mixing up
what the
daily combo [ __ ] oh by the way coach is
gone now coach is gone gotta give it to
cardi for that smart parenting move
let's hope offset feels the same about
cultures nails go like this so i could
see him better
oh snap
daddy
[Music]
you